ce en train de décoller pour toi j'ai
envie de lancer aussi trois nouveaux
artistes john deere pour tous lequel a
le plus de chances de devenir une grande
star avec malice et premier concurrent
c'est jean michel l'actuel
je
c'est 8 nuls j'avais dit avant très bien
qu isabelle la scie à bois
c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
bref c'est une
franchement c'est une bombe 7 et enfin
on abat jama le burin
[Applaudissements]
on savait que c'était pas terrible pour
moi là moi la grande gagnante à méribel
vous êtes une photo et les beautés
argonnais elle est magnifique izard est
magnifique télépathique et lavabos en
tout cas merci
théo donc c'est pas un délire on va te
suivre à fond on va mettre la chanson
très souvent sache-le et continue à nous
faire marrer comme ça merci c'est venu
comment la chanson que je suis ton grand
chipolatas comme ça à la baisse excède
belles chansons où j'étais un cadeau du
coup pour eric antoine
ouais et en fait je me suis dit moi
c'est chiant et puis je rassure cherfi
dit tu vas sortir un album bourré 2021
ouais j'ai déjà six titres ya quoi comme
au titre à paris
c'est le grand succès et comme aladdin
que j'ai déjà fait l'an dernier à la
france n'est plus le talent c'est bien
et bah écoutes je suis ton gros
chipolatas yahia ou is la saucisse si
rodriguez la merguez
merci tir au lavabo conquis on vient de
voir quand tu me merci théo
[Applaudissements]